à partir de ce samedi on va ouvrir un
numéro dédié pour que toutes les
personnes qui parfois se sont découragés
n'ont pas réussi à voir les rendez-vous
ont trop attendu et bien puisse en
appelant ce numéro délié obtenir un
rendez-vous prioritaire pour avoir dans
les prochaines semaines
leur rendez vous ensemble de vaccination
et se faire vacciner avec le kaiser du
high tech ou avec le moderne
la deuxième chose c'est qu'on a d'autres
centres qui nous disent nous on a fait
tous les personnes de plus de 75 ans on
a on a réussi nos objectifs mais du coup
on est plus remplie à plein et donc à
partir de ce samedi
nous avons décidé d'ouvrir à la
vaccination pour les plus de 70 ans dans
les centres de vaccination avec le
kaiser et le moderne